as we continue with monsoon season heavy
rains have found their way into homes
and buildings that's right our very own
jeremy j ford visited an apartment
complex at eastern and sahara with
extensive water damage and spoke to
mitigators who were there to evaluate
the damage
[Music]
this apartment has over an inch of
freestanding water which forced
residents to relocate and find a new
place to stay and the places that
they're giving us are basically rock
gates
drug influences with limited relocation
options long time resident donald wilson
says his apartment is ruined from water
leaks due to heavy rain you got a lot of
rent from us and you don't want to
do anything
to fix a roof insurance estimator
stephen moyes is evaluating the damage
and encourages both renters and
homeowners to get insurance it will
cover basically your personal property
and you know out of state so i'll give
you a place to stay if you're a
homeowner who suffers damage make sure
you notify a restoration company as soon
as possible if you find a leak in your
home
get it fixed don't wait because then
you're going to end up paying more money
in the long run
because sean grant says your safety and
health could depend on it it's something
you need to take care of yesterday not
wait till next week or whatever the case
may be because you have the potential to
get mold which is something that can get
you and your family very sick jeremy j
ford eight news now
well sean grant says the cost to repair
water damage to a home usually runs
around fifteen hundred dollars if caught
early he also says if you think you have
a water or mold problem to call a
mitigation company as soon as possible
for an estimate which is usually free of
charge